Olá minhas amigas meus amigos conforme
vocês forem entrando por favor me avisem
Como está o áudio eu estou usando o
microfone sem fio que é de alta
qualidade mas eu tava usando só para
gravar os vídeos do
canal não usei em live ainda então
preciso saber de você se o áudio está
legal então se tem já alguém
assistindo Por
favor me avisem sobre o
áudio eu queria falar com vocês de dois
estudos e depois nós vamos
partir para responder as perguntas como
sempre né primeo estudo interessante que
eu já tinha comentado isso em vídeos
anteriores mas vale a pena a gente
discutir um pouco é que a saúde da boca
tem uma relação muito intensa com a
saúde cerebral então é muito importante
cuidar bem dos dentes das
gengivas que pode trazer benefícios além
da saúde bocal incluindo a melhoria da
Saúde cerebral Então isso é uma coisa já
bem conhecida mas um estudo recente
corroborou isso aí
enil boa noite por favor me fale se o
áudio tá ok me dá um feedback por
gentileza então em um grande estudo
observacional com adultos de meia idade
que não tinham histórico de derrame ou
demência
a saúde oral ou bucal ruim estava
fortemente associada a vários marcadores
de neuroimagem marcadores de lesão na
matéria branca do cérebro obrigado
pelo feedback Eliana e também nild me
digam se a o áudio tá melhor hoje do que
tava na semana passada ou tá igual ou tá
pior tá me dá essa posição você tá
melhor igual ou pior da semana
passada então o estudo avaliou
marcadores de
neuroimagem e esses marcadores precedem
fatores de risco estabelecidos para
derrame e demência Então os resultados
dos exames perdão resultados dos estudos
sugerem que a saúde
bucal um processo que é graças a Deus
modificável com a certa facilidade
pode ser um alvo
promissor para você ter intervenções
muito precoces para evitar a degradação
da Saúde cerebral Obrigado Fernando
Obrigado
Eliseu então parece que deu certo esse
meu setup aqui de microfone sem
fio Então esse estudo foi publicado
online em 20 de dezembro de 2023 na
revista
neurology os dados vieram de 40.000
adultos com idade média de 55 anos um
pouco mais da metade eram mulheres e
esse pessoal todo não tinha histórico de
derrame ou demência eles se inscreveram
num banco de
dados do Reino Unido de 2006 a 2010 São
banco de dados de imagens né e fizeram
ressonância magnética cerebral entre
2014 e
2016 desse total 14% que corresponde a
5470 pessoas tinham saúde bucal ruim que
era definida pela presença de dentaduras
ou dentes
soltos os que tinham saúde oral ruim
eram mais do sexo
masculino e tinham também maior
prevalência de pressão alta colesterol
do sangue alto diabetes
sobrepeso obesidade um histórico de
fumo então no modelo multivariável a
saúde bucal ruim nesse estudo foi
utilizado essa análise estatística foi
associado a aumento de 9% no volume de
hiperintensidade da matéria Branca esse
marcador de hiperintensidade
é um marcador conhecido de doença
cerebral cérebro vascular
silencioso então a saúde bucal ruim
também foi associada a uma mudança de
10% na pontuação de aí é um nome bem
técnico eu vou tentar explicar isso de
anisotropia fracionada
agregada e uma mudança de 5% na
pontuação de difusividade média agregada
tá são duas métricas de imagem de de
difusão que representam a desintegração
da matéria Branca então vejo que esses
marcadores são todos de matéria Branca
cerebral e foram Associados a a saúde
bocal
ruim então análises genéticas usando
randomização meliana confirmar as
associações
indivíduos geneticamente propenso a ter
saúde oral ruim tiveram um aumento de
30% no volume de no volume de
hiperintensidade como eu comentei na
matéria branca uma mudança de 43% na
pontuação de anisotropia e de di fusid
média tem esses critérios técnicos que
dizem Como é que tá a saúde da
substância Branca cerebral ou matéria
Branca cerebral né a gente fala
eh não é no português a gente fala
eh substância branca ou substância
cinzenta né no no no inglês
é eles falam
de matéria Branca né no caso seria White
matter Então essas descobertas
acrescentam evidências epidemiológicas
anteriores de que uma associação de
entre saúde da boca ruim e maior risco
de resultados clínicos relacionados à
saúde cerebral incluindo declino
cognitivo Então esse não é o primeiro
estudo como eu já
comentei os autores de um editorial
acompanhando esse estudo elogiaram os
autores porque Eles olharam para as
consequências da saúde bucal ruim de uma
maneira poderosa com marcadores
objetivos de imagem usando essas lesões
de matéria branca ou substância branca
que foram definidas por ressonância
magnética E essas lesões é muito
bom como marcadores porque elas
antecedem o declínio cognitivo em vários
anos Isso é um poder muito grande que dá
tempo da pessoa tomar medidas para
prevenir isso
aí os dados da Organização Mundial de
Saúde sugerem que as doenças orais que
são em grande parte evitáveis afetam
quase 4 bilhões de pessoas no mundo
inteiro três em quatro três a cada
quatro pessoas afetadas em países de
renda
média Imagina os países de renda baixa
né então ISO foi financiado em parte por
bolsas deut institutos nacionais de
saúde da American Heart Association e do
neurocritical care society
research ess é o primeiro estudo
obrigado pelo feedback Denise
pedan o segundo estudo
pessoal é um estudo para mostrar
segurança
cardiovascular da terapia com
testosterona foi um estudo feito com
pessoas cogon adismo ou seja com baixa
da
testosterona e foi publicado numa
revista
muito
respeitada uma revista de Cardiologia e
na verdade England JN of medicine parte
cardiológica Esse estudo foi
compartilhado pela Doutora Rachel Rubin
com o Dr que
que foi um um desses participantes desse
estudo né um dos pesquisadores o estudo
se chama
traverse e Resumindo os resultados desse
estudo em termos de segurança
cardiovascular
eh foi observado que não tinha diferença
dessa segurança entre as pessoas que
utilizaram o gel de testosterona entre
as que não
utilizaram então isso já é um um rebate
de medos pregressos de que a
testosterona poderia aumentar o risco
cardiológico o risco cardíaco em termos
de função sexual a terapia com uma dose
de testosterona transdérmica Aumentou a
atividade o
libido mas nesse estudo Não aumentou a
ereção em termos de câncer prostático
Esse estudo foi mais um que confirmou
que não aumenta o risco de câncer
prostático ou uso de testosterona
[Música]
e Melhorou a anemia
significativamente
Ok
então as implicações práticas desse
estudo são significativos pros médicos
que cuidam de homens de meia idade
idosos que TM
hipogonadismo confirmado e tem alto
risco de doença cardiovascular Então os
resultados sugerem que a ter Apia de
reposição com testosterona pode ser
considerada uma opção de tratamento
viável sem o risco aumentado de eventos
cardíacos adversos
importantes isso é particularmente
relevante dado as preocupações
anteriores que tinha relativo a
potenciais riscos cardiovasculares com a
testosterona os médicos podem ter agora
mais confiança para prescrever sabendo
queem provável que essa terapia vai
proporcionar aí um problema
cardiovascular mas houve algumas
alterações negativa nesse estudo houve
um aumento da incidência de fibrilação
atrial eu não acho que tenha sido por
causa da testosterona Mas isso foi
achado no estudo também houve uma
pequeno aumento de risco de problema
renal e embolia
pulmonar então esses riscos específicos
T que ser verificados aí com mais calma
o que acontece que eu vejo na prática
pessoal que quem usa testosterona e não
tá cuidando estilo de vida não tá
emagrecendo não tá comendo menos
carboidrato não tá fazendo atividade
física tanto aeróbica quanto de força ou
não tá dormindo direito a testosterona é
como uma gasolina ela acaba aumentando
alguns processos
biológicos e se a pessoa tiver fazendo
uma atividade física regular isso vai
ter um impacto positivo
mas se ela for sedentária tiver comendo
mal e obesa isso pode ter Impacto
negativo
Ok então vamos às perguntas de vocês
deixa eu abrir o
arquivo
bem vamos lá primeira pergunta ah deixa
eu mostrar na tela aqui para vocês
verem deixa eu ver deixa eu ficar
sozinho aqui na
tela deixa eu ampliar aqui um
pouquinho tá dando para
ler Boa noite
Isaac eh Fernando tá perguntando se o
estudo que eu acabei de falar mencionou
a quantidade de testo no sangue não na
verdade eles deram uma dose padrão até
meio baixa é 10 mg por ml e só
verificaram as complicações tá o
objetivo do exame não era ver o nível
sérico eu acredito que não tenha essa
informação eu vou dar uma uma
checada pera
aí
já te respondo
tá vamos aí pra pergunta da marlu Doutor
ouvi dizer que coentro abaixa a glicose
estão devo Então como devo consumir em
Natura chá extrato o coentro é melor
você comer mesmo na alimentação coentro
totalmente comestível né Você pode pôr
na alimentação é o jeito mais fácil você
pô na comida se você não tolera o sabor
você pode comprar o extrato de coentro
Tá mas o coentro não é o
mais importante ou
mais intenso aí na redução da glicose se
você tá com preocupação muito grande com
glicose eu
utilizaria uma berberina ou o Milão de
São Caetano alguma coisa assim não é o
coentro principal para baixar a
glicose Francisco Weber a el carnetina
apresenta
vantagens na
suplementação ou o corpo já produz
aquilo que
necessita a carentina é muito bom para
obeso porque ela ajuda a betox dação das
gorduras então ajuda a queimar gordura
Ok depende da pessoa tem pessoas que vão
pro produzir ele carnetina suficiente
outras
não ela tem um bom custo benefício para
emagrecimento sim ó Eu acredito que tem
um bom custo
benefício tá deixa eu responder a
pergunta
aqui do Fernando né o estudo em
questão eles receberam então como eu
tava comentando é
1,62 de testosterona gel que vai dar 16
MG por
ml e a dose foi ajustada para manter a
testosterona no sangue tá entre
350 e 750 nanog por dcil
esse Range né essa faixa foi escolhida
para refletir os níveis fisiológicos
normais de testosterona em homens de
meia
idade Ok então houve sim aumento de dose
alguns pacientes para manter nessa faixa
de 350 e
750 Mas como eu falei o objetivo
principal era ver a segurança vascular
da terapia de reposição com
testosterona certo então acho que foi
respondida essa pergunta
aí vamos pra
próxima Quais são os efeitos negativos
da reposição de testosterona quando se
faz o básico é basicamente você ter
aterosclerose que é aumento da
especialmente da parede das
artérias pode aumentar o grau de
inflamação no
organismo e pode alimentar um câncer de
próstata oculto a testosterona por si só
ela não provoca câncer de
próstata Mas se você tiver um câncer
oculto ele vai crescer dando
testosterona então a met aterosclerose e
pode aumentar até a obesidade e o
inchaço da pessoa se ela não fizer
atividade
física mudança da alimentação
gerenciamento estresse e do
Sono Ficou claro então que foi a
pergunta da Denise e da
enil vamos voltar pro questionário
aqui próxima pergunta modulação hormonal
Idêntica para mulheres na menopausa
apresenta quais
riscos se você fizer testosterona
isolada na mulher ela pode aumentar a
aterosclerose risco de infarto Então tem
que usar estrogênio e testosterona e
progesterona Qual o custo médio não sei
responder Francisco vou chutar aqui uns
R 200 por mês mas precisa ver com a
farmácia quais seriam os fitoterápicos e
suplementos indicados para Tais
pacientes
fitoterápico para o quê para reposição
hormonal aí não é mais reposição
hormonal você tá fazendo fitoterapia né
Tem gente que não quer fazer repos monal
tem tem medo de câncer de mama tem medo
de câncer de ovário E aí usa
fitoterápico Quais são os principais o
licorice Né o Mor nigran que é a Mora o
black Oros
o
Angélica censes tá são os principais tá
mas aí já não é reposição hormonal é uso
de
fitoterápico Francisco Doutor trabalha
com a modulação monal bêntica para
mulheres sim
trabalho uso do antiparasitário Anita é
seguro geralmente é Tem pessoas que não
toleram o Anita mas a maioria pra
maioria é
seguro
ele gera proteção contra novas
infestações Por quanto tempo
depende Geralmente os três meses ou ao
ser eliminado pela urina não apra mais
proteção não ele vai dar uma proteção
por alguns meses tá mas se a pessoa
tiver no ambiente muito contaminado ela
pode se
[Música]
recontamination Vital de Complexo B O
Cobavital é remédio suplemento vamos lá
deixa eu abrir aqui
a o site que eu vejo para nome
comercial é um
suplemento certo ele é uma
combinação de uma forma de vitamina
B12
é uma B2 sintética
tá
não tem tanta informação na bula do do
cobá Vital Mas é uma B2
sintética
certo Deixa eu ver se eu respondi a
pergunta Dizem que o COB Vital faz o
corpo aumentar o limite de absorção de
proteína para transformar em músculo É
verdade não sei não tá escrito isso na
bula Não eu não sou digamos assim não
estudei profundamente esse suplemento
não tá porque ele é um nome comercial e
é vendido em farmácia
comum muitos ingerem comat Vital para
prática musculação já que aumenta o
apetite você recomenda se for uma pessoa
bem
magra né E que tem dificuldade de ganhar
peso a recomendo agora para boa parte
das pessoas is é ruim porque vai ficar
gordo em vez de ficar forte
soube que o cobra Vital faz a pessoa
Dormir bastante durante o
dia não sei dizer sobre isso
viu tá falando que bloqueia o sono
rein tá deixa eu dar uma olhada aqui
numa outra fonte tá vou ter que ver isso
em tempo real porque eu não tenho
experiência com esse cobá Vital nunca
prescrevi mas ele é sim uma forma
sintética de vitamina
B12
tá onde eu tô pesquisando agora em tempo
real não tá dizendo nada que S aumenta
músculo não tá dizendo que não não
aumenta
músculo só se a pessoa for esse tipo de
indivíduo que é muito magro e não
consegue ganhar massa muscular porque
não consegue comer o suficiente e malhar
o suficiente aí nesse caso específico né
que geralmente são jovens que são
eh do
tipo
ectomorfo aí vai a pena tá utilizando
isso aqui
tá não tem nenhuma evidência que piore o
sono pela pesquisa que eu tô fazendo
aqui
agora mas um é possível que deixa a
pessoa um pouco sonolenta em alguns
casos os efeitos colaterais é sonolência
tontura que é raro boca seca visão turva
náusea vômito constipação excitabilidade
eh a pessoa que fica assim quieta e
nervosa tá isso é efeitos colaterais
raros e parece que quando aparece também
são
leves certo vamos pro próximo
então Ó eu nunca prescrevi isso aqui
pessoal tá ess cobá
Vital
a Live da próxima quinta-feira vai ser
entrevistando uma doutora Carolina
Fontes que é especialista em
fitocanabinoides tá respondendo aqui o
Eliseu ao praticar jejum intermitente
essa dieta aqui vai quebrar o jejum
eletrólito não quebra o jejum
multivitamínico também não quebra três
colheres de sopa de óleo de coco não
quebra limão e sal rosa também não
quebra tá tudo isso aqui que você tá
falando não vai
quebrar significativamente o jejum
hum cortisol bioidêntico tem efeitos
colaterais mesmo sendo bioidêntico tem
tem sim se você usar uma dose alta vai
ter efeito colateral sim a vantagem do
cortisol B idêntico é que ele é 1/4 da
potência da Prednisona que é o corticoid
mais comum só que se você usar dose alta
você vai ter muitos
problemas já notei que nos vários vídeos
YouTube que você fez sobre Alzheimer
você colocou no títul Expressão fim do
Alzheimer esse nome fim do Alzheimer é o
fim do livro é nome do livro do d breen
tá por isso que eu usei esse título Ok
esse salvei meu pai do alz não é vídeo
meu tá esse é vídeo da jolivi Ok e nem
por isso você foi punido o YouTube ele
não pune os títulos mais
sensacionalistas tá pelo contrário o
YouTube gosta porque as pessoas clicam
tá porque às vezes você tem um conteúdo
muito bom as pessoas não clicam
simplesmente porque o título não é
apelativo Isso é uma realidade dura do
YouTube ok então o que o YouTube pune as
pessoas é se você entrega conteúdo
mentiroso mas é mas muito pior do que
isso é você entregar conteúdo que eles
consideram que não é a verdade lá do
establishment tá eles gostam de
punir reparei que você não colocou no
título a expressão a cura do
Alzheimer não ô Eliseu isso aqui são
escolhas de t t tá como eu falei salvei
meu pai do Alzheimer não foi nem eu foi
jolivi que colocou isso aí
tá São escolas de título não tem nada a
ver com punição do YouTube tá
Ah li num livro do protocolo Coimbra que
ele receita 20.000 microg de B12 20.000
microg Não não é essa dose tá errada
tá 200.00 microg Seria 20 MG de B2 uma
dose muito
alta
É verdade que não existe dose tóxica
parcialmente verdadeiro Tá mas 20 MG é
muito muito muito muito alto eu não
usaria essa drose
e altíssima a dose de B12 dá um
benefício extra não quando a dose de B12
é muito alta é verdade que o corpo
Guarda para ser usado não o B12 ele é
uma vitamina de depósito sim mas se você
usar uma dose muito alta vai ser
eliminado na urina não a capacidade de
armazenamento é
limitada qualquer um pode tomar 20 MG
não eu não tomaria 20 MG de b122 nem a
pau máximo que eu dou de B12 é 1 MG por
dia tá nunca vi benefício de D mais do
que isso agora se você viu
esse isso no livro me me mostra porque
tô achando estranho isso
aí
soos possui magnésio treonato confirma
não sei tá tem magnésio tem você tá na
forma de treonato não tenho certeza Qual
o n possui magnésio treonato não sei
procurei na internet e não encontrei a
quantidade de magnésio treonato na nos
borboleta tá vamos ver isso aqui em
tempo real também porque eu nunca ouvi
falar que tem treonato na nas
nozes eu não sou também onisciente Tem
coisa que eu não
sei mas isso não é tão relevante também
né você não vai comer noses porque tem
ou não tem magnesio treonato você vai
comer nos pelo
perfil nutricional da da da das nozes se
você precisa especificamente de magnésio
treonato é melhor tomar na forma de
suplemento pela pesquisa que eu tô
fazendo agora aqui as nozes não têm
magnésio treonato
Ok e essa forma não é encontrada
naturalmente em
alimentos o que pode ter na na nas noses
é o o aminoácido tá
astronômico e o magnésio mas não os dois
juntos complexados
tá tá perguntando mais de nós aqui ó
ingerir todos esses alimentos no mesmo
dia você acha melhor consumir l stoso no
café da manhã não Melhor dividir porque
vai dar diarreia comer muitas nozes tá E
é individual isso a quantidade que vai
dar de Aria individual de pessoa para
pessoa é melhor ingerir no mesmo dia ou
dividir em dias
diferentes O que as variedades de noses
é isso tanto faz isso Eliseu isso não é
relevante tá e a e a erança de nos
diária vai vai depender de cada
pessoa qual nível ideal de pth por volta
de 20 Aliane o ideal de pth é por volta
de 20 se você tiver fazendo um
protocolo lá do Dr Cícero G Coimbra aí o
pth ideal nessa circunstância seria em t
de 12 que é um pth já
suprimido Isaac valores de colesterol
HDL 72 D 77 36 40 qu será o total 188
são valores bons para
idoso isso aqui é um pouquinho
disfarçado tentar fazer consulta né
Isaac eu vou responder de maneira por
alto tá a relação aqui entre
triglicérides e HDL tá boa né Tá muito
boa HDL até maior do que a triglicérides
tem só que vê se esse HDL 72 não pode
ser problema hepático mas tá muito boa a
relação
os números aqui estão bons
tá porque o colesterol tá baixo de 200 o
trigliceres está bem abaixo de 100 o LDL
tá abaixo 120 E o HDL tá acima de 50
então e em geral seriam valores
excelentes Fernando castelani vejo muito
a respeito de alimentação alcalina
alcalinizar o corpo bem como de que o
câncer tem preferência por ambiente
ácido Isso é uma simplificação tremenda
do assunto tá é para leigo poder
entender mesmo porém sangue tem um phar
constante Com certeza tá
correto o nosso organismo autorregula
exatamente tem os buffers né os tampões
o osso é um grande tampão né para
regular o o sangue dessa forma é
realmente possível deixar o corpo mais
alcalino essa história de corpo alcalina
é uma coisa muito confusa como eu já
falei em outros vídeos porque assim cada
compartimento do organismo tem um PH o
sangue tem um o início tem outro dentro
da célula tem outro tá líquido cfal
liquidan é outro urina é outro então é
cada líquido do corpo cada compartimento
é um PH Então a gente tem que tentar eh
manter a quantidade de minerais
especialmente o
magnésio e o potássio no nível
adequado para que o organismo não tem
puxar esses minerais do osso para
compensar o excesso né de acidez que na
verdade esse excesso de acidez não vai
se manifestar no p ao no sangue porque
senão a pessoa morre porque o corpo já
corrige isso antes então mas pode deixar
o osso fraco por exemplo tá então esse
pul essa esse equilíbrio alcalino é
importante
eh porém não precisa tomar bicarbonato
de sódio é basta comer vegetais que aí
você vai conseguir e ter os minerais
necessários para poder equilibrar esse
PH no organismo Ok eu não recomendaria
usar bicarbonato de sódio
eh o tempo todo para isso eu não sei em
situações assim de
emergência porque o bicarbonato de sóo
vai deixar o seu estômago por exemplo
alcalino né Isso é ruim para você porque
o ácio do estômago é importante paraa
digestão então O bicarbonato de sódio
vai ficar alcalinizando toda hora o seu
estômago então não não recomendo você
ficar usando dis isso daí tá
bom Anita axan que é o Anita é um
antiparasitário que também possui
propriedades antivirais sim é verdade
como diminuição carga viral superior a
90% em vitro considerando uma hipotética
nova epidemia por vetor viral poderia
ser utilizado em tas oxan Não sei ainda
né Vai depender do vírus né Pode ser que
o futuro vírus aí não responda a lentas
oxan a gente teve só vamos saber
testando né caso
aconteça aí você tá me pedindo para ser
o volter mercado né
para conseguir prever o futuro tá
pedindo nesse caso hipotético qual seria
a dose e posologia sei lá meu vamos ver
tomara que nunca aconteça se se
acontecer a gente vai ter que ver na
prática né e qual que é o prazo de
utilização da nitazoxanida sem que
houvesse dano hepático p
easo sanida não é para ficar usando
todos os dias tá é para usar três dias
seguidos e
parar e não é que nem a a IV mectina
nesse ponto
aí por que que na biorressonância os
resultados são tão diferentes dos exames
laboratoriais excelente pergunta Liane
excelente pergunta por que eu diria para
você que é
porque a bioressonância é uma coisa
extremamente subjetiva esse que é o é é
o ponto e o exame não é Eu
particularmente entre bioressonância e
exame se tá não tá batendo eu confio
mais exame agora se você perguntar isso
para outra pessoa vai te falar outra
resposta eu não confio tanto assim em
bioressonância
quanto pessoal às vezes
confia qual o suplemento que não pode
tomar quem tem câncer Glutamina ou
creatina seria Glutamina Tá mas eu eu
questiono essa situação aqui eu acho que
exageraram muito nessa história de
Glutamina vai virar glicose e vai
alimentar o câncer tá já tá provado que
o câncer não é só por causa de glicose
existe alguns cânceres sim que se
alimenta de de gordura e copos
cetônicos O que fazer quando as Fes
estão finas investigar primeiro se você
não tem um problema no colo no intestino
grosso com a
colonoscopia se não tiver nada lá na
colonoscopia aí é caso a caso geralmente
melhorar o microbioma melhorar as fibras
os
prebióticos o que poderemos esperar
dessa próxima epidemia Poxa alian também
vai ser mesma história não sou volta é
mercado né quem sabe prever essas coisas
é o pessoal que solta esses viro na
natureza aí né não sou eu infelizmente
aí o Bill Gates talvez posso te
responder melhor essa pergunta né o
pessoal do for econômico Mundial né esse
pessoal aí que tá por dentro isso daí
né eles estão planejando a próxima
pandemia
eh 268 de D dímero tá bom está pessoal
mas por favor não me mandem exames para
analisar já avisei isso antes tá
insulina ideal é abaixo de 10
fetin de 42 é muito baixa depende tá
mulher seria mais ou menos homem é muito
baixo laranja é uma boa fonte de fibras
para quem está limpando e regulando o
intestino para tratar constipação e
excesso de gases se laranja é uma boa
fonte de fibras o bagaço da laranja sim
é uma boa fonte
de de
fibras
as perguntas ao vivo
aqui doutor para mulheres que querem
parar de menstruar e aliviar sintomas de
TPM com menor risco possível de
problemas de saúde como risco aumentado
de câncer de mama qual seria o método
mais
adequado
Na verdade o quando você suprime a
menstruação por exemplo com
gestrinona isso é um
elemento anti estrogênico tá então o
estrogênio que é o principal problema aí
que leva câncer de mama e de
ovário
então não existe esse aumento de risco
de câncer de mama quando você suprime a
menstruação através de de Agentes
antiestrogênicos
E aí depende da da da pessoa Fernanda
tem gente que o melhor método seria usar
um dia hormonal e tem outras pessoas que
o melhor método seria usar gestrinona Se
for mulher atleta a gestrinona
geralmente é
melhor faço o jejum intermitente jejum
de 24 horas uma vez na semana estou
malhando com objetivo de ganhar massa
magra minha pergunta vale a pena parar
com
jejum tá realmente jejum não combina com
ganhar massa magra
viu esses dois objetivos seus estão
batendo de frente um com o
outro se você quer ganar massa muscular
você vai ter que sair do jejum
intermitente
mesmo seria bom você fazer uma
alimentação a cada três ou 4 horas com
cab hidrato complexo e
proteína se existe aumento de risco de
DHT com uso de testosterona gel existe o
que fazer nesse caso depende primeiro
aplicar o gel numa região que não tenha
pelo isso reduz o risco aí você vai ter
que medir no sangue se o DHT tiver muito
alto você vai ter que usar libidor de 5
al redutase né um sal pometo por
exemplo
Roberto Mendes Esso aqui não é para mim
se você quiser eu posso postar agora um
livro lá no grupo
Whatsapp é Tem um pessoal que faz jejum
intermitente musculação sim tá mas não
combina muito não vai atrapalhar o ganho
de massa muscular A não ser que você
faça assim tem você pode fazer um jejum
por
exemplo você janta faz um jejum de 12
horas aí antes de treinar você come
carboidrato com proteína para dar um
pico de insulina depois da atividade
física é uma estratégia só que você vai
certamente ganhar menos músculo do que
ganharia se não fizesse o
jejum sim magnésio treonato pode ajudar
dormir
sim mas noses não tem magnésio treonato
viu Eliseu não tem confirmei essa
informação essa alcalinização por gestão
de alimentos veget seria pela ingestão
dos minerais sim seria pela ingestão dos
minerais presentes nos vegetais
principalmente por isso de
nada a pergunta sobre o Anita é
exatamente por saber que provavelmente
não teremos informações simples sobre
ação de fármaco sem patente não eu não
não precisa pedir desculpa não Fernanda
é porque enfim a gente não tem como
prever o futuro é só isso
tá vamos horar e não teremos a pandemia
é sugiro fortemente Que vocês orem como
a Estela está sugerindo aqui beijão
Estela
querida
eh não não é exatamente ser cobalamina
não é uma forma um pouquinho diferente
tá É verdade que o suplemento zinco não
deve ser ingerido em jejum porque dá dor
de estômago Eliseu só por isso não é que
faz mal não é porque geralmente o zinco
irrita um pouco o estômago só por isso
mas Z carnosina não Zino carnosina não
dá esse problema
não crononutrição é
importante por exemplo tem estudos
mostrando que os muçulmanos que T mania
de comer muito tarde da noite né quando
eles saem lá do aliás no ramadã em si
eles não podem comer durante o tempo que
o sol está e visível né durante o dia
então eles têm hábito de jantar tarde
isso atrapalha a saúde cardiovascular
sim então a crononutrição
importante qual melhor wayi Protein é
uma combinação de ui Protein Isolado com
hidrolizado tá Fernanda esse que é o
melhor R Protein Tem várias marcas que
tem essa Associação tá isolado com
hidrolizado
ã pessoa que tirou visícula pode tomar
chá de boldo do chile para
fígado essa informação Eliseu tá um
pouco composta demais aqui eu vou tentar
achar a resposta porque você tá me
perguntando
tá o bodo do Chile como ele é um Agente
colerético né ele ajuda a estimular a
função do fígado e liberar a pile ele
pode ajudar pessoas que tiveram a
remoção da vesícula
biliar só que o boldo tem uma substância
tóxica chamada
ascaridol que pode danificar o fígado
Então tem que tomar cuidado não exagerar
Na
quantidade já o caso aí da
alcachofra
ela também é muito bom pro fígado reduz
a inflamação do fígado promove o fluxo
também de bilha colerético
também tá deixa eu ver se eu respondi
sua
pergunta sim então a resposta é sim pra
questão do bolo do Chile ajuda mas não
pode exagerar Na quantidade e a cachofra
sim também a colerético ajuda
também
não o a espinheira santa não é que ela
produz ela ajuda o organismo a
produzir não ela não substitui o
suplemento enzimas digestivas ela
complementa não três castanhas do Pará
geralmente tem por volta de 100 mgr de
celeno que seria o suficiente paraa
necessidade diária das pessoas Tá agora
você vai eliminar todo Mercúrio
provavelmente
não sim a melhor canela é do Ceilão e
aquela canela que não é a verdadeira
pode fazer mal sim dependendo da
quantidade sim Fe forme banana e sem
resíduo é o
ideal a dieta é muito mais importante do
que suplementação de probiótico tá
Eliseu na verdade o probiótico ajuda mas
a dieta é muito mais poderoso do que
qualquer tipo de
probiótico Na verdade o prebiótico que a
fibra é mais importante que o
probiótico Bem pessoal vou encerrar Já
estamos com 47 minutos de Live senão
Ninguém vai querer assistir depois a
versão gravada tá nós nos vemos na
semana que vem muito obrigado pelas suas
perguntas e pela sua participação um
grande abraço um beijo no coração de
vocês
l